London's roast restaurant opened in 2005
it promises to serve deliciously British
food with the finest seasonal
ingredients head chef Stuart Caldwell
used to work for British celebrity chef
Gordon Ramsay but says he learned most
of his cooking skills from his mother
Coldwell doesn't have far to go to buy
ingredients
London's Borough Market is just one
floor below the market dates back to the
13th century nowadays it's a hit with
foodies and restaurant tours
today's Stuart Caldwell will be serving
John Dory the fish is caught in the
Atlantic Ocean just off England's
western coast Caldwell says it's nice
and fresh still moist sit a little bit
sticky you can see that the eyes is
still quiet what oh the fish has the
shape of a discus that makes it
difficult to fillet so this is best left
to the fish monk cauliflower and chicory
will be served with the fish most of
what's sold at the borough market is
produced in Britain the dish is prepared
with red and yellow chicory orange John
Dory filet and cauliflower the sauce
requires raisins
chicory and the fish in the cauliflower
will all balances out each other because
the chicory is quite fit serve but then
the Arias orange helps the cauliflower
and the John Dory and then the
fruitiness of the good golden raisin and
then you've got the nuttiness of the
pine nut to finish it off first the
chicory is sliced lengthwise the red
chicory adds color to the dish just
adding some orange zest and icing sugar
red wine vinegar and red wine to the
chicory they just end houses all the
flavors
the chicory is heated in the oven for no
longer than 10 minutes to caramelize it
then cauliflower milk and butter are
heated in a pan to make a puree a lot of
chefs use that you can got with Paige
with quality in our just a pure rice
it's more delicate on the bottom of a
quail this is followed by the dressing
Stuart Caldwell mixes pine nuts mint
raisins and lemon-infused rapeseed oil
can add a twist to the dish just
something I made up really yeah
chili infused or regular rapeseed oil
can also be used instead the John Dory
needs little preparation just a little
salt and that's it and legend has it
that it's black spot is really st.
Peter's fingerprint it's a luxury fish
it doesn't take much cooking assault
it's quite thin it's not it's not chunky
meats of this still only take it's
literally two minutes to cook the fish
must be fried carefully it's best to use
a lid so the fillet will not curl and
will remain a feast for the eyes
flip the fish ones
always used a bit greaseproof to help
protect the skin finally the dish is
served John Dory with chicory and an
orange blazing cauliflower puree and a
pine nut and raisin sauce a satisfying
but light lunch in Britain's wintery
capital
you